greetings from podcast Ville the Church
of what's happened now is brought to you
by manscaped listen you got no baseball
you got no basketball
you got one UFC fight you got another
one tonight right now it's just you
sitting there scratching your balls on
the [__] couch time to make them look
like the 84 [__] Mets
Mookie on the Left Keith the man is on
the right everybody's ready to go listen
the engineers at manscape they've
created the perfect ball hair trimmer
you've noticed when you saw the benefit
from the Comedy Store my balls were
perfectly [__] shaved that just
didn't miraculously happen that's the
lawnmower 3.0 they smooth out your
scrotum with a new ceramic blade and man
escapes advanced skin safe set
technology for you [__] in the back
that means it won't snick or snag or
nothing on your nutsack no more [__]
thinking is gonna cut that blue vein am
I gonna bleed to death your balls on the
area on your dick of fine why does uncle
Joey told you why I live on manscape I
got I had a man scape here like this
sometime just scratching your balls you
see a out of place it even has an LCD
LED light on it so you can pick up your
leg in a wig yoga position just get that
little [__] hair out see you [__]
your nutsack everywhere on the [__]
blood bowl of life is ready to rock now
I'll tell you what I'm gonna do
you gotta subscribe alright you get a
new blade every three months that's how
you keep your balls extra clean they got
this thing called the perfect package
you get a lot more plus the croppers
preserver so your balls don't stink
stick together and you get the revival
listen I live off the revival I'll tell
you what else I still got most food
manscape
I still got if you have you looking at
this on YouTube I got the [__] - man
screen just because that's how I roll
I've shown to you during the performance
these are individuals in case you bump
into a [__] flying around you ever
see like a blue Rob but anyway do me a
favor right now
go to [__] manscape I'm gonna take
care you're right
right now for the church family I want
you to go to manscape and press : Joey
Joey why Joey Joey @y and manscape
listen I don't know if the beach is
opening by house but you don't want to
show up with a [__] afro coming out
of your legs get some [__] manscape
and even if you get the ticket it's
worth because you showed you dick to
somebody you know [__] it and they're
gonna give you 20% off and free shipping
that's cold Joey at manscape dot-com for
20% off and free [__] shipping
limited time only right now if I was you
it's the summertime shave your [__]
nuts and manscaped heads as the answer
speaking of shaving your nuts what good
is shaving your nuts if it's not gonna
work we're gonna show up with a gum
we're [__] four bullets you're
[__] [__] that's what Joey comes in
with blue chew remember when your dick
was a [__] you remember that when
your dick was just a a piece of [__]
meat wrapped around with a [__]
little vein like a little string like
your mom's pot roast but you dick wishes
hard and all of a sudden life goes on
and things happen and mental attitudes
change you [__] the same person for 11
years
yeah you're not getting that [__]
same stomach gistic you getting this
[__] week wood well again Joey Diaz
your uncle got the fix blue chew it's
the first first chewable dick bill which
means it works fast
bucho has the same fda-approved act if
active ingredients is Viagra and Cialis
and this isn't horny goat weed you get
from [__] meltdown at the [__]
liquor store this is science
blue chew is prescribed prescribed purse
groomed prescribed online by licensed
physicians so you don't have to go to a
doctor's office and then go to [__]
pharmacy forget about all that dish
shifts right to your door what I'm gonna
do is this right now today we got a
special offer for the church family I
know a lot of you like joyful
can accusing me of having dead-stick I
didn't say yeah that's take what not
what I'm telling you is maybe you got an
extra special date and you want to leave
a tear in the corner like a [__]
runaway give a [__] a chick because
she's just like shaking and trembling
that hasn't happened for me in 30 years
but when I was 20 21 22 25 I was doing
blow with chicks they'd be like in the
corner when I come out from cleaning my
dick like I can't take it no more
that was too much that's the kind of
dick you want to give out
that's better than a postcard that's
better than a tweet that dick word of
mouth dog I slept with that [__]
I wasn't the same for four days that
means he put that dig all away and yes a
dick you want to be slinging it's 2020 a
chicken bite you owe for the quarantine
you wanted to be quarantined for two
weeks after that he gave me such good
dick
I'm quarantined in for two weeks that's
the dick you get when you eat Blue Cheer
right now so go to blue chew visit blue
ChiCom that's blue to BL you eat you
calm pressing code Church CH you are CH
I pay what they're gonna do they're
gonna charge you five hours for shipping
that's it blue again blue like the
[__] color of the dick vein that's
gonna pop out when you hit it with blue
chew all right and thank you for
[__] for listen now let's kick
this [__] melee it's Wednesday
like of Malaysians ban the church
[Music]
[Applause]
what's happening you bad [__]
uncle Joey here it's Wednesday morning
the 12th of May guess what you still
locked up your miserable [__]
they just locked us in till June [__]
30th who gives a [__] at this point we
got each other listen you may not have
no money you may be [__] licking dick
for a living whatever you're doing I'm
sorry you're in this position I hope
you're not feeling bad if you're feeling
you know I don't even like saying the
word please call call hit me up on
Facebook Twitter Spotify whatever the
[__] you got I'll answer you okay
there's a time of the year people
feeling bad I'm here to change that
around so for starters if you gotta join
let's Park this [__] I don't
care if it's esquina
Who am I to judge it's [__] Wednesday
you know I'm saying me I'm smoking a
little [__] I don't even know can
kiss the door Matador something from
[__] urban trees they always take
care of me over the end studio Studio
City I've been to a Boulevard I love
smoking reefer as much as you
[__] do I don't know about
drinking and then jumping up and down
and going to birthday parties but reefer
and some music listen to somebody
reading a good book this is what it's
all about this but this quarantine is
about writing a little bit whatever but
here but for right now you're here with
your uncle [__] Joey last week we had
Georgie on part 1 we're just talking
about us me selling weed to the Indians
and [__] spraying the bottle and now
we're talking about the kidnapping but
it's weird I'm really happy I'm taking
this time to talk to some of my friends
I'm not we're not going to criminal
stories the people we mugged or whatever
I just wanna tell you that after 40
years I still talk to the same people if
I have any accomplishments at all in my
life it said I've kept these guys around
to keep me grounded that's why you don't
see me at Hollywood parties that's why
you don't see me acting like a Mook
[__] the law because in my world I'm
still one of them I owe it to them these
people I put on the podcast and DC
develop these guys all I thought about
it my darkest times when I was having a
hard time and going
I give this go too easy we're also coke
no no those people invested time in me
and I still got more people calling in
then I got a call and tell you that half
these people invested time and me they
gave me money when I was down and here
we are 30 years later we're doing a
podcast and we're just reviving those
[__] stories now they impacted my
life you know it's a beautiful [__]
thing when I could give back and you
know that's it but it's [__]
Wednesday unemployment I don't know
whatever listen get a gun I told you
that eight weeks ago I tell you to get a
gun and to get refunds just in case he's
using that walking down the street he's
on the [__] cell phone
now you got the mass you halfway there
you got a white mask on put the gun in
his rib this I'm just gonna take your
wallet remember if I take your wallet
you didn't see my face hit him with the
dinero line I know who you are you know
we are and just run down the street ten
days later by that time you're in your
car is Wallace in the sewer
whatever I'm not telling you to [__]
be a thief what I'm telling is you got
to get up off your ass and [__] house
I don't know what else to tell you I'm
saying I'm doing the same thing in my
world I'm almost ready to do cameos like
I'm ready to [__] call people up hi
my name is Joey Lee told me to call you
and say that you're a [__] stinky
[__] I don't want to do that yet you
don't say I'm still trying to make Payne
some [__] dick with you dignity I
guess I just can't but I got mouths to
feed this [__] home school is killing
me you know we all have issues during
this the issue for me as the men this
being alone none of that [__] bothers me
I don't give a [__] if I ever go
anywhere again [__] about planes trains
or automobiles
what concerns me is my daughter you know
it's uh how well-being I saw how you
know you look at these [__] 23 year
olds too late 30 35 year olds I will
[__] [__] I'm trying to I'm not
talking about no I'm not talking about
you yes I am anyway
I just feel that you gotta take your kid
in a different way we somewhere we
forgot the parenting thing so I'm taking
this as seriously as I can't
she's at the house with me right now
we're gonna draw and she's gotta read me
three [__] books or Tuesday don't
[__] work out tomorrow we do a
podcast or Wednesday don't work out we
move out and move everything around we
used to do a podcast on Tuesday
now we've moved at the Thursday because
she's got a play there I'm Tuesday at
1:00 and I this is what I'm trying to do
it I know I don't put the kids together
they have face masks and they don't land
on the same spot they ride their bikes I
don't have the kids together in circles
when we get together we don't get
together with more than two kids it's me
and my wife her and our husband and the
kids and that's how it's been working
out but that's why I have to do for her
to have peace of mind
she also FaceTime so guys comedy is done
call me assistant principal Diaz that's
what I am now
I'm an assistant principal I'm checking
the homework at night I have to [__]
you know draw with her I'm also a
part-time Jim I'm the word gym teacher
cuz I sit in a chair and make it throw
kicks and punches just I can't squat
that love and I can't put like I go on
my knees but I can't stay there for that
long so have to sit while she throws
kicks and punches about but I'm doing
all this because I know that I could
just leave her in the room all day you
know and I could sit in my room all day
and I tell you what that's not gonna fly
because that's how the rest of her life
is gonna be she's gonna have a [__]
love affair with that [__] room let
me tell you something I used to have a
love affair of my room but from time to
time my mom would come in and grab me by
the hair and say you gotta go out you
gotta go you gotta go
like you can't sit here all day and I'd
tell her well I'm scared scared of what
would their kids just get the [__] out
there being four or five and then she
used to kick me out then there was some
times when I was six and then when I
went to cat for school on Saturdays or
Sundays when I first lived in North
Bergen
I should have been hanging out with
these guys that they've been calling in
for two years I lived in North Bergen I
never went out I only was there
Saturdays and Sundays and Friday night
Friday night I'd hang out with Union
City kids
Saturday hang out with by myself in an
attic in the mornings I'd stay in a
[__] attic all [__] morning till
this day I hate that [__] attic till
this day I'm pissed off what I am on
that attic but we'll get that [__] later
I don't like kids stay in it I really
don't I don't like the concept of games
I want you to learn to play a game but
you know what you get more you get more
from playing a basketball game and get
an elbow to a head then playing [__]
battleship do you know him Sam
like I didn't like I wasn't into I was
the only thing that was around when I
was growing up with like Mario Brothers
whatever the [__] that was right and you
weren't gonna catch me out of couch
you just want gonna catch men accounts
to kids I ran with warrant cats things
they played hockey they played stickball
they ran they play basketball without
you know I talked to emprender Monica
police go there they had a close
encounter Park down where I'm from in
Jersey and thank you guys for joining
the hills of North Bergen Joy Lepore the
moderator of that page reached out to me
there's a lot of guys new podcasts want
to join that Bates
that's a [__] interesting page
because joy Alipore is two years older
than I am
and he rides those hills on a bicycle up
and down every day he does a new [__]
video of him the other day he went down
the second steepest hill in the country
he went down on the by yeah he survived
the [__] yeah Jesus join the poor has
been right listen if I would have stayed
and I would have ridden my bike or the
skateboard or the the [__] what he
didn't he call eight things when the
snow hits a sled bro behind the police
station there is a hill but if you look
at you like I don't know I did it like
10 times growing up and like almost
crashed into cars you know because this
cars coming the other way
were sledding down a truck yeah and the
you ain't stopping the momentum behind
the police station that hill car my
bowels anoles father lived on that block
and whenever it snowed he drove us over
there and me and a bunch are they in a
nine dead Devils there were kids that
walked up there dragging that thing
looked down and said I don't think so
because in those days that the shovel
would come and then the it would pad the
snow up against the car yeah but if you
hit like a tire with your head you would
done how you know a [__] tire skids
went to the hospital on that [__]
thing I'll tell you why I'm living one
time I'm exaggerating one time some kid
threw his shoulder out didn't you have
like a hill that we had a hill Michael
pills every webinar on the street it's
the second Helius city in the country so
why didn't you why didn't have to do it
on the street because what we are doing
in the grass yeah no that's [__]
right we went down a hill we went down a
hill on a bike with no helmet all right
you take your chances some of us will
walk around squeezing the ball
some of us all right we're talking I'm
saying oh my god yeah there's nothing JA
wears out but he's 50 [__] seven
about 59 I hope he wears Alamut yeah he
was almond but [__] 30 years ago
helmet you either [__] or weed smack
the [__] ideas and break the humbling
when you were a kid you shut up with a
helmet it was getting broke I don't wear
a helmet for snow tubing or like
sledding but we did our grass over I
can't imagine doing it on cement
concrete oh that's how you stop listen
how you stop you had a hit song
you didn't just stop on this rad North
Bergen bang Oh Mike it was like that
thing from [__] I wouldn't uh Wide
World of Sports do you remember that I
we've talked about it I've seen it the
guy falling and he tumbles and [__] the
beginning you've never seen that now
look at intro to Wide World of Sports I
don't give a [__] okay if they take this
down we're not gonna show it but look an
intro to why do all the sports that
didn't even start as a [__] real
intro he did that it fell apart
and ABC border from him the beginning of
this is how you had a stop when you were
a kid in my neighborhood tell them what
the link is okay I'm gonna try this one
says it says Wide World of Sports
intro 1978 on sad sounds about right
they can't and watch it right no okay
they can't see it as long as they can't
see it we won't get but they can hear it
I turn that off they can if they want to
I can put it in what's this guy that was
me that was me turn that back now
there's a [__] video on you stop that
stop that cuz there's a video on there
that shows that skier doing that for
from beginning to end and then turning
off the cam and going [__] I didn't know
it's gonna be that bad no mi a-b-c got
the footage one way or another that's
how I stopped there was no stopping on a
ski sled you stopped by hitting the car
taking out of another pedestrian or just
seeing a we would bang into [__] Egizi
swore my man Anthony and Dean egg Izzy's
house was right there you go into the
house no we just stopped at the wall you
got a stitch you just went home and got
stitched up and came back I can't
imagine us beef sandwich and you came
back oh my god crazy these capsules you
gave me are pretty good I'm talking dog
what the [__] you think you're [__]
with you think like III make [__] up at
night I caught myself slurring the other
did you give me that night yeah I was
slurred I ate like [__] nine of these
things oh this is ultra ultra pills from
[__] didn't what's the name of this
company I'll tell you what the name of
this [__] is I get them every once in a
while when I get bored of edibles but
when I get bored of everything I switch
them or you know I like to switch my
edibles around alright you gotta switch
your edibles around
and I'm doing a lot better anyway cuz
I'm not eating as many edibles that
break really [__] help me wait when
you take a break take a break after my
psychological breakdown and March I
didn't talk about it publicly it's
nobody's business but then I started
getting bored again I go what's a
quarantine without an edible eating I'm
saying so I went over there one day and
I got a box of these [__] things
these pro tabs I get the indica ultra
loaded and they're working in fact
I made did you eat - I'm going for like
[__] ate them [__] dick it's Wednesday
you know planning for that if it hasn't
happened it ain't gonna happen if it
hasn't happened in your world yet are
they gonna happen so give us a [__]
for what the week the month the whole
[__] thing it's Wednesday we didn't
make it happen if you didn't make that
happen so far anything gonna happen I'm
lying you listen to this Wednesday
morning something could happen
you still got today probably but if some
don't happen by tonight nothing's gonna
happen tonight you get it tonight you
get up you leave you go home you know
what the [__] am I talking about you're
not even at work after you [__]
[__] what you do is you [__]
but I don't know about two o'clock call
my bookie put two hundred in there let
them give you a hundred and bet 300 on
the fight tomorrow night tonight you
gotta fight tonight no you kidding you
got a nice little fight to share against
[__] Anthony yeah that's a nice
little fight for you so that should take
care of [__] board and so you put on
come on bull Joey and boom and if it
don't happen tonight
they ain't gonna have until next week
you're insane
wait what are you saying that we just we
still got a bottle of quickies to drink
this ain't a party until the [__]
until Sophia Loren walks in and I'm
saying these people forget you forget
we're not here to [__] around we're here
to tell a story
we got joined you coming on part two you
know I I hope you people could tell
George in mind
friendship just by our conversation I
hope you're enjoying these I hope you're
listening to I hope you're not listening
to expect something else I'm not trying
to make these funny or anything I'm
trying to show you the connection I
still withhold with all my own friends
on what they mean to me this guy means a
lot to me and a lot of dog I've gotten
hit on Facebook I got some ammunition
coming for you [__] we're gonna
give you a break we're gonna give you a
little comedy break for a few episodes
then we'll go back to my friends now I
know they're an option and now I know
they're willing to tell their stories
one of the best stories I forgot to tell
with Georgie because he didn't want me
to embarrass him was Georgie was
hammered one Sunday in the afternoon and
what I don't get a [__] pen here I
get the [__] do this by myself hey
what do you got there a little plant
there's a boy oh there you go now we
just drank a little hundred milligram
quickly zo2 get the Daystar that's 9
a.m. we're already making that you hear
that you talks like this that's out of
respect for you [__] for
listening to the show anyway back to the
show story with George it's a Sunday I'm
holding on to like a [__] strong $19
$19 and I can't budge I can't even bump
into a nickel the reason why I needed
that all I needed was five at $10 more
to going through the city I could walk
over get a bag of dope maybe some Cuban
food it's [__] Sunday I deserve I
don't want you to win these bear though
I'm better than these but we need to
Wendy's Burger [__] Sunday so I get
up I do my thing I don't know no car
sales that day I'm not doing anything
and no well there
what arrow we're gonna talk about now is
pretty much and then 93 but I lived at
George and Cliffside Park and I used to
work six days a week I'm on this Sunday
hat off I wake up I he breakfast
somewhere and I come back and George's
laying on the [__] couch like the
Zombo and I'm sitting man there's a lady
who was upstairs not a good looking lady
not even the nice lady she's kind of a
break she was always a prick to me you
know I always said mean things I know
her in grandma wards or your war with
Grandma your war with me so I see her
house side Grillin with her kids and I
go she's outside grilling a purse is
upstairs I'm guarded so I run upstairs
and sure enough the [__] front door
is open because I don't know what you
people thinking you lock every door I
don't give a [__] if you got a bathroom
you lock the door I open the door I
never it is sure enough a [__]
pocketbook with a purse sticking out of
it with cash so I take the [__] cash
put in my pocket close the door and I
run down the stairs and I go on the room
like nothing now I know they're gonna
blame George I [__] know this that
they're gonna blame George I take the
[__] money account that's eight bills
I came out that I think a downstairs to
the basement and I hide it and I go back
upstairs well I just wait and sure
enough within the hour we open the door
and it's a lady always George somebody
stole my money from my apartment and I
know is him there was a television
missing about a year ago I know it was
him and it wasn't me I wasn't even
living there a year earlier so the
grandma George's grandma was like what
are you accusing my grandson of stealing
your money and she's I guess he stole my
money
you know I'm calling the police and
grandma says call the police George
George and George was getting up out of
a [__] deep A's he doesn't know
anything
she goes you you still have money and
joins us like I just woke up
what the [__] are you saying I've been
asleep ask Coco Coco's was day with me
and I'm like yeah I'm just waking up
myself
you [__] kidding me I was already
showered I may believe I was taking
[__] that so now the cops come the
cops are getting involved they pulled
George outside they pull grandma outside
I'm sitting like ouch [__] I'm [__]
watching the sports baseball like
nothing happened and all of a sudden the
cops leave grandma comes back and George
comes back in George was so out of it he
didn't realize what had been really even
missing I waited about an hour I went
downstairs and put my best shirt on I
went downstairs I got that 800 I took a
cab to the [__] sub to the bus
station
I took the New York bus I took the a
train down I took this girl out to
dinner I had this little relationship
going on with this little girl from
Boulder she was a waitress at the comedy
club of them so boom I come back that
night I feel guilty I stopped I get a
couple grams do two loads whatever I get
some cash and I throw Joy's like 100 but
I never ever say this to him but I
robbed that lady so years later
me and George reconnect like in 2000 99
98 and I go George what's going on and
then he you know I go choice normal Dan
the lady came and she said that you
robbed them and he goes he looked at me
with because he knew he goes it was you
I go yeah with me you know I robbed them
so what laughing you know he's like I
took the [__] blame
she broke my balls for years after that
blast fast forward to about six months
ago
it's a Friday night I'm in the town I
don't know what time I'm at I'm about to
go on stage and the phone
mr. George and I could you that's why I
don't text that's why I don't text
because I want to hear your voice when I
picked up the phone I gets from the
sound of his voice I can hear his face
was pale no George what's the matter he
goes she's not gonna believe this
I'm at this bar on inclu side and this
young girl sitting next to me and one
thing such do another I start talking to
the bartender and I told her I grew up
with him with Terrace and then she says
that she grew up on him with Terrace
also and I asked the way she grew up and
she told me the address and I go hey
that's my address and she goes yeah I
lived in that building upstairs from you
you and your grandmother the fact I
remember your grandmother she goes we
moved after we got robbed so George
turned pale he told the chick thank you
and he called me right back and he goes
[__] 27 years later that robbery
still [__] haunts me anyway enjoyed
part two with George child in ski my
brother kicked this [__] Emil Julie
[Music]
what house to Dodge Chrysler Plymouth
and you know I tortured and though the
debt the Indians find that I'm putting
water in their weed with torturing Jim
Roberto Jim Roberto ended up hooking up
with that good-looking chick and got a
pregnant yeah yeah finance - finance she
was beautiful now yeah she was a good
lady - its wife was its what yeah he
ended up smacking her around years later
they divorced but so I got into beef
with Jim Roberto with Roberto who was a
sweetheart of a guy my oak addiction at
that time I was up probably five nights
a week
you know I was snorting coke five six
nights a week I mean I didn't even sleep
I was sleeping probably two hours a
night one night a week I and then the
other
I was probably sleeping one night a
[__] week and you would more nights
at the restaurant then I started working
more because Roberto mound of firemen
right Jim Roberto hold on there's more
the story I ended up we ended up moving
getting the two-bedroom house in south
boulder across Chile from arouse yeah
and they had a strip mall and then the
seafood guy at rouse was a Cajun from
New Orleans and they used to make this
different food and that was another
place I never paid the seafood again oh
man I yeah
let me tell you now first of all we had
Hercules it was the world's best dog I
mean he was like it was like Carlos you
got a little remember this back then
Coco wasn't there with he was
hospitalized in fact we had a heavy bag
in the backyard every day his shoulders
were rocked out he literally had fists a
[__] steel it was like Bowie no I
wasn't sure how was this shape I was in
really good shape me pants bro you were
hit
bag everyday Hercules was jumping you
know we were having a ball you know was
it just cold
we were doing [__] we were young kids I
mean kids were 25 years old you know
said oh i remember his party will endow
falcon i bought up I bought a patoot a
newspaper a TV and a VCR now we got like
a 19-inch to TV we got a BC long before
this we had nothing we had each other at
night we would lie down at night drink
and look at each other and I'd go to
yeah you know I would go there and you
know food sucked but but they had him
with that fella meatball grinder the
[__] grinder they called it but uh so
I remember when we got bigger mushrooms
you remember that we get a bag of the
shrooms and song remains the same was on
cable so me you and Hercules got some
stems and we like big we but we split
like an ounce of mushrooms whoever half
ounce each we were [__] tripping and
laughing and the dog was [__] rolling
on his back at me and that was a crazy
movie to watch back that just lost um
you know and our main thing was Miami
lights like that was one time so every
Friday was Friday night to nine o'clock
and I know 20 times and I remember about
that time do you remember there was a
280z found in not to shot be scented by
our house Cuban kids but a Cuban kid and
the one by work and he was shot
it is like red you know 280 seen the
body they just found the they just found
the car covered with blood it was you
know Boulder Colorado
university of colorado and whether they
got 50,000 students that go here so we
right now who knows when school's out
it's a ghost town the you know that now
you're talking about a small town it's a
city you know now I went there I don't
know ten years you go there more often
now but I went back in like 2006 will my
daughter playing softball and it's a
city it's a sin it wasn't him at City
don't know is it cops there was what 20
cops it wasn't it wasn't a big very
small town that wasn't them no you know
it was 40 miles with them so it was a
small town mentality and you know I'm
not the brightest guy but I'm smaller
than everybody [__] they just that was
the thing that we had I think we we just
had a different mentality and we we were
caring but if you had a weakness weak
you know you found that weakness people
were too [__] nice it were you know
and it was a New York bias you know they
didn't really own me personally they
didn't you know older at the time they
were prey for her quick that would take
California to the ocean because that's
what they want then it was like
California would snow we're all laid
back you know bulldozers very Boulder
was a very very very nice town it was
nice to live in we had the world by the
balls but like now I'm ashamed to go
back to Boulder because of all the bad
things like that route Supermarket I had
the dog I never paid for dog food we
would shock I used to just walk on the
way I would put it under the [__]
supermarket thing and just walk out of
the supermarket with it or I just pick
it up and walk home with dog food the
routers like my personal [__]
playground is that way
yeah we would go in there and literally
buy like a ping of bananas and a couple
of apples maybe a box of cereal because
really Coco's E is Iron Man cereal it
was like working out back there Iron Man
Iron Man Syria and then we would stick
like like [__] like Animal House we
would stick steaks and chicken and all
of this we would wear baby shirts and
one guy today would like meat and then
go to register and pay you know four
bucks and then on top of that a 50-pound
bag of shrooms on the way out and then
we became friends at the butcher they
loved it and they had no idea we weren't
paying that's on what's Taylor then we
became friends at the butcher who was
again from New Orleans and he would say
to me I did this for you today
he would make he's the first person ever
to turn me out the fish kebabs
he'd make my swordfish with shrimp and
all these things the marinade and the
jump and a gumbo laia type thing like a
seasoning and I was going then he'd give
me for them and I'd put him under my arm
buy a six-pack of soda and I look at the
way to go the girl go I already paid for
these at seafood she would never even
ask me like it was just like it was just
it was like a free-for-all you know the
money I was making
I sold coke to snort coke so every day
somebody called me that was looking for
Coke and I would snort coke and it was
like George is my roommate but George is
doing his thing and I was doing my thing
it was the weirdest life now when when
did you start seeing the change in me
that you felt something
well you know it's funny because I
remember I didn't I was a [__] pig I
remember I used to like do my laundry
remember throw it on my bed I should
sleep on my laundry
like I didn't have drawers there I just
had like a [__] pile of clothes which
I brought way too many out there but
what happened was a couple of things
remember so that or Lent we were we had
this little routine he watch the TV then
one day we walked in and the TV and the
vcr got stolen and it was like can we
only had like three have four people or
ever over to the house so that kind of
like dampened everything you know now we
don't have it you know you know we had
money for everything else but not the
one thing that we really enjoyed doing
with my home you know which was who's
watching TV so you know you were a
little pissed off because you knew was
someone you know I didn't know anybody I
thought it was you and you thought it
was me like we know in my mind I'm like
he thinks I stole it cuz no I mean I had
a man right you had every right to think
that way no no but I remember like it
was I the first time I saw you faint you
we were freaking out on me about
something I would have cuz I'm annoying
so you know I am yes hello Zoe I think I
didn't do the dishes or something and
you took the dish in your [__]
smashed it you know and you like clean
this up so you went out with Cathy came
and uh you know I clean up the glass I
do the dishes I put the [__] plate in
the garbage but you're hung about he
comes in comes back in it kind of
apologizes to me any went to throw
something out and the [__] fish got
my own dogs were robbed the [__]
plate sliced his arm like [__] four
inches white big oh yeah you got a scar
still not one away uh it went away
I got good skin but you know after we
apologized he went through the garbage
and now he's like what the [__] and all
of a sudden bloods coming out all of a
sudden boom you go sound like a [__]
tree in the forest am I such a tough
[__]
a child and went to sleep yeah next
morning and dealt with it the next
morning and you needed stitches I wasn't
that was like just going to sleep with a
wound yeah I don't I don't go to this
hospitals I don't settle to know that
[__] but I could tell that George I
could tell that I wasn't happy it was
about and it was I think like I loved
George but I could tell it wasn't
working family and I got a job in a
frame shop yeah I gotta be happy to do
that it was critical for me either
even though I had a girlfriend and had
all the directions I had everything I
wanted I had my best friend with me I
had a job but if I didn't do coke I was
making money if I didn't do coke I'd
make money at that job that you know
paid forty five six hundred a month okay
that the hell a [__] [__] can't
make money off forty five hundred a
month not go to college to make forty
five hundred a month at night in the
whole thing but something just wasn't
right like I had a problem then that
everybody has that they did their own
worst enemies yeah they're their own I'm
your I'm my own worst enemy I get in my
own way yeah I got into an argument and
I left you you stayed working at Jim
Roberto's this is how I know oh and I
come right it I quit but you stayed
working at Roberto's and then I went
over the bill crowd super which is a
hundred yards away from you right right
there was a hundred yards away it was
down the block and I want to work over
there and I still remember like the
second day like going back over there
but I didn't really want to be there I
come back it folder
back at Boulder shrine uh whatever
Hollis I started at that place
I'm like why and my [__] in here what
the [__] am i doing at this place I
started here and this is a criminal
place this is what criminals hang out
but there was money to be made there
yeah you could make a lot of money at
that place so Subarus you just had to
learn how to cut through the red tape
they had a new manager named Wayne means
who was a great guy and they had a guy
who had my back named Jimmy wheeler
Jimmy wheeler was someone exceptional
men that I've met in my life he took me
under his wing and he goes you're gonna
be fine this time nobody's gonna [__]
with you Baba Baba Baba there was a guy
named grant whew Smith that was a floor
manager there you didn't know him he was
kind of a scumbag in a way but I go to
work over there and I mean my second day
there my second day there like I leave
[__] chrysler-plymouth so I could get
my life together like that's all I
wanted to do was just be a good salesman
make money and figure out a way how we
can make money get the [__] out of here
and go back to North Bergen with a
[__] pound the blow like heroes I
wanted to be a hero
meaning you with a parade throwing
packages out to the street you know
that's what I thought
and my demented cocaine mind that's what
I really thought see he didn't have like
goals for like no [__] goals for
nothing my goal was to be a drug kingpin
like they were on Miami Vice my goal was
to have a blonde than a Testarossa and
to have a boat and to have parties on a
boat but I didn't know how I was gonna
get that water all these things but I
couldn't even [__] control myself to
go for a [__] walk like the only
thing I did positive in those days was I
stuck the hit in the bag and walking
Hercules everything else I did was
negative there was nothing positive I
took classes at night
at the University College
you were getting very depressed yeah
what'd you do you still do like as
November rolls around him right now
unlike your childhood friends I didn't
know you when your mother was a lot I
knew you after what I did know at that
time of year came as he approached
Thanksgiving though Ron died November 8
right so there you go a little crazy a
little back and that's when this [__]
was was was growing up and you were not
agree you know you lost a pep in your
step you weren't you you changed you
know internally what happened was that
George Here I am I'm in [__] Boulder
Colorado I'm doing good for my standards
I was doing very good I had a job I was
making money I probably had insurance I
was driving the car I was dressing nice
but that wasn't good enough see my
friends in North Bergen was going to
hunt the mountain every weekend snort
make walls of coke and that's what I
wanted to do god forbid I could do the
right thing in those days
god forbid I could do the right thing he
always made a choice sometimes second
[__] day at Bill Crouch little group
they hire a Salesman I look at the guy
he's been there before and I thought you
had gotten rid of all these type of
people so they hired two guys but I knew
it trouble one guy's name was Tom on Oh
hm one of those guys that was a
good-looking blonde surfer dude he
looked like the guy that stole the chick
from John Travolta in grease
he had that wrinkle me you had that
wrinkle look at the end not to Nikki the
other guy that had the ugly girl charts
at the end Oh your hand time baby oh
yeah
all that [__] and he had bad like he was
just uh a [__] scumbag type of
[__] dude so I know we're talking
about we told my super dude I as his own
guy and this guy named Bella Knight no
I'm dollar Bella was a very good-looking
guy [__] magnet
but Bella hung out with the Gebhardt
boys who won't get part BMW there were
rich little boys they praised my selves
like Leonardo DiCaprio and they had
money when you were at a bar and again
part boys walked in there was a big deal
you know there was three of them they
had Coke they had blow they had booked
[__] and their father home to BMW
store Bella was a hanger-on to them nice
kid but I could tell I was gonna flip
this guy somewhere along the line in
those days whenever I met you it was
just to size you up you were allowed to
do what you did because I let you do you
never sang and like you saw me in 85 you
know what I went through our EES window
I wasn't scared of nothing and if he was
home I want to kick them in the stomach
what my frame of mind in those days was
completely different than the frame
might I have now you were going down it
was either you and me and if it's you
and me you're gonna go down and guess
what
nothing's gonna happen you're not gonna
call the cops you're not gonna do
nothing because I break your [__] I
was out of my mind I was angry I was
angry about my mom I had no time to [__]
around I would [__] stab you there's
no time so I'm on the car lot two days
and then walks this [__] Kent fella
and sure enough like I'm pissed I'm
really really this is hard to sell but
I'm telling you people that I'm pissed
because for the first time I just want
to sell cars make 10 grand a month and
get myself out of this position so I go
home
be a regular [__] guy I'm out here
living with these [__] bumpkins
wearing [__] Birkin socks driving
Subarus I'm from the land the Cadillacs
and white shoes and I'm saying
why you wearing [__] Birkenstocks
floor more capezios I'm gonna bleed
nothing you know you gotta go see live
music three hillbillies singing let it
skinhead I couldn't take it no more so I
remember it was Monday Night Football
and I called my gas kalise and it was in
October but he's telling me about these
parties they're having up and hunt the
mountain they killed the bear with
cocaine they [__] did this and this
and I'm like what am i doing I'm taking
two classes a week at the University of
Colorado I'm dating this chick who's a
very nice girl
and we're girl I got a John here with me
we're not doing [__] together you know
he's over there making hourly wage I'm
over here [__] fight for my life and
two days later Bella gets hired and he
says to me can you give me a ride like I
mean ten in the morning I'm already
aggravated that he's there and I'm like
god damn it I can't bring a [__] guy
here who does coke this is the last
thing I need I just want a job where
people are normal but sure enough you
know flesh is weak like the Bible says
Matthew tells me you want to take a ride
to the jeweler liquor store
you know most people went to lunch he's
like let's go to liquor store went to
liquor store he gave me two bumps of the
[__] that was ultrasonic that did it and
then that night I go can you get me more
of this and he drove me to his house
because my roommates got two pounds if
you could [__] help me steal it I'll
give you some I got a DUI because at
that time there were three major news
things that happen in Boulder one thing
was that Cuban kid got beat up he never
found his body
number two another drug dealer got
broken into in his house and he was so
scared he jumped out the balcony and he
broke both his legs
and number three there was something
else lurking something else had happened
so I meet Vela we go back to his house
the first night he shows me the coke
tells me the deal they would want to do
and I get in my car to drive home and I
already know I'm gonna I'm gonna Rob
this [__] but I had a big
problem George I wanted to involve you
but it wasn't your cut you're not that's
not your thing
you're a good getaway driver you're a
good guy this you're a good you're good
at a lot of guys I remember you gotta
initially you met him
you're like listen 12:45 grab Oklahoma
Drive meet me at the Chrysler dealership
it's gonna take 20 minutes I'm gonna run
in and out and I'm like are you sure he
goes yeah Tuesday definitely Tuesday
12:30 you call me I work at like 12:00
and you're like you know what it's not
good we're not gonna do it so I was
initially I spoke to my attorney so I'm
not legally a there's no conspiracy here
but we were gonna do it but then it
turned from like two days you know and
we're gonna do it Thursday then you're
like no no no no
so now was like the next week and I'm
like you know what there's no way that
that's there whatever you saw is not bad
you know like is autonomous and now you
move out mr. toad well that's where he
came in and I'm like you know what good
luck because it just doesn't and you're
looking awfully like you know no no no
because all those days even when I lived
in Jersey I was doing one to [__] but I
would never involve you cuz you had a
mom and a grandma and a dad and then it
was never one involve you that was glad
that was my big thing leave we're gonna
do this but that part I'm gonna do
because
if I get caught I have I have nobody you
got a mom and a dad you just sit in the
car you get that gun ready you got my
back but I don't want you doing this
if anything happens take off in the car
you would just sit back there talking to
a friend don't do time I was old school
if I did a crime I'm doing the time cuz
you got parents I don't have parents and
that was my motto
now what level of crime like were you
the only one taking the food out of the
grocery store was just for big stuff
that George couldn't do we both took
food like that those are little things
I'm talking was involved know how to
kick down the door or something I would
never take a friend of mine that didn't
need to be there I would say to you I'm
gonna kick this office in I want you to
park over there and watch my back listen
to the police scanner you know whatever
you need to do so I'm safe but as soon
as you see a cop don't play cowboy don't
go over there just go home let me figure
it out I'll run I'll call you that I'll
call you at 11:00 at this payphone if I
make it out of there I'll call you at
this payphone so that was the thing I
didn't want George involved I woke up
that morning it was a Tuesday morning
18th of November I know you weren't
happy with your life I wasn't happy with
mine and I went to the dentist his name
was Kevin Sesa MD I got my teeth fixed
and it was like it was like everything
else in my life it was decided right
then like it wasn't planned it was like
when I left Kevin assesses and I got in
the car I called Tidwell he says
everything was in place
I called Vella he said the coke was
ready and I go I'm coming over there to
pick you up you didn't even know it was
going on I went to valas I walked
upstairs he did a couple lines with me
he showed me some money
so I knew there was [__] in the house
yeah
like alright I go where's the kilo and
he goes he's got a hidden in the synth
ceiling
yes that was a popular hiding place
everybody's had suspended ceilings yeah
yes no I [__] did what I had to do I
drove Bella we've had this story once
before I drove them you know when I got
that kid wall I go back Ted whoa
bring Tidrow a sample tidwell's gonna
take the sample of his people get money
and then come back and then we'll figure
out how to rob them Tidwell jumped the
gun as soon as I gave Tidwell the sample
Ted will rip out the machine gun and
instead of saying Joey get in the room
he involved me in it already so now Vela
knew that I was in on it it was supposed
to play out that he was robbed and both
of us I was even gonna empty my pockets
he was a [__] but Tim was a [__]
[__] so once Tidwell did that I was
stuck already so I we you know you had a
handcuff Ted well whatever Vela put him
in the room with the pit bull and then I
sent Tidwell over there now I knew there
was 1,800 in the draw
what Tidwell came back he said there was
300 in the draw and right there I know
he was [__] to me and there was only
an 8-ball there was a lot more coke in
that drawer there was one an ounce and a
half and chunks in that draw so I said
okay [__] and I can't believe
you're doing this to me he goes why what
are you talking about I didn't know what
the [__] to be talking about like a
little 32 but I had had from my Aspen
Colorado days that even you didn't even
know about it and I was thinking of
shooting them both George I was thinking
of just shooting them both cuz you know
where the house was nobody would
not my house had tidwell's house I was
for one second there I said I'm gonna
shoot both these [__] cuz this
is gonna go this went wrong already this
is already wrong I got miles in my
pocket and [__] a little bag of coke
this could not have happened for this
and I knew was gonna happen George I
knew I was gonna I knew was gonna [__]
up somewhere along the line it was my
civic duty to myself to go on with it I
went over the 22nd and Canyon I went
right through in their house I [__]
ripped down I ripped that house apart
and I found more coke than that was in
there so this dad can't tell you what I
did with the coke I don't know I know I
brought some home
I brought some home a little bit home
and I gave you some you went to the bar
and I stayed in the apartment no and
then but a lot happened that for that I
came home I told you I was done we were
nervous Kathy king came over she had a
perm then me and her got into an
argument outside and you came out and
stopped us and then Tidwell came over
and he goes I want you guys to go on a
ride with me I got another hotel we can
rob do you remember that because I
needed the money by this time he needed
the money badly but he had tried to [__]
me so I said [__] you you're not [__]
me now you need the money more than I do
so he needed the money for a stripper
that yeah that wasn't he needed to get a
divorce before she sucked his dick I
mean this whole story is just [__]
this is the gang that couldn't shoot
straight this is me being one idiot
Kidwell being another idiot but this was
God's Way of telling me this had
happened you know I'm saying like this
has to happen so you don't remember us
being back at the place arguing and then
valor knocking on the door and though I
remember is you did go to cats you wind
up with khakis
because I already remember the cops
coming to the house know what happened
what didn't know ship right yeah what
Apple was that night an internal fence
tonight like kidnapped Vela I went back
home you went out I got pretty [__] up
on the couch I had to think about my
next move I didn't know for the guy I
gave the coke too if I could trust them
I didn't know how long till I was gonna
get the money I needed to get you and I
a plane ticket out of there because
either that or the Chambers Brothers are
gonna come get us
that's whose coke it belongs to Greg
chambers oh I still remember his name he
was the original dealer that that fella
was holding it for Craig Chambers
something like that so chambers are
still gonna come looking for us so I had
to figure it out so I said you know what
I'm not gonna figure out nothing I'm
just gonna sit here snort coke and when
I wake up in the morning I'll come up
with an idea there's nothing to do now
it's 10 o'clock Ted well was all Bela
was already in the trunk when Ted wall
came over to the house he had Bela
already in the trunk and he goes I don't
know what to do with him I don't know
but there's one guy that has a hotel
that has ash we could go take him down
like our wind doing nothing
our relationship is over you shouldn't
have [__] me at Bella's house I didn't
[__] it I just didn't find it I know yes
you did it's in your pocket I go get the
[__] out here and don't come back and
then he left
you went across the street to the fish
market
I [__] stay in the apartment and I
passed out when I woke up the next
morning you were gone I didn't even go
to work because I didn't have to be at
work till 2:00
so I woke up to banging on the door from
a guy called I don't know redheaded guy
white dude freckles
he had Brett blazin Brett Hazen no that
was
his name blazing Brett Hazen from where
well who is this guy
tessie he was from Colorado he lived he
was the white man at bill crowd Subaru
at the time so the cops had the building
surrounded he got a car ran to my
[__] house banged on the door and he
goes dog the cops got bill crowd Subaru
surrounded swats over there they're
looking for you but they're trying to
get your address
Wayne means is fighting them off as we
speak because they had the old address
from where you and I lived like they
didn't have the new address so I had a
couple minutes you were gone you're gone
so now I get two minutes he says I gotta
go I washed my face I eat a handful of
[__] Ironman cereal then brush my
teeth and I run across the street as I'm
running across the street I could see a
detective cause I go now I go to that
routes I get a legitimate breakfast and
I call my now ex-wife girlfriend at the
time and she's in the head color in
school do you remember she was in
headline school now I'm calling you
because I could call you at the lot but
you're on a delivery run you're not
answer it
so finally I'm sitting in I'm like what
the [__] am I gonna do with this rouse
or King Soopers King super King Soopers
I go what the [__] of my goodness King
Soopers I got cash I got my wall I got
everything I need I got more than what I
need I even got coke on me but guess
what I don't have reefer yeah I just had
a brand-new batch of reefer I used to
put in a purple bag do you remember used
to borrow my weightlifting gloves then
maybe I got mad at you cause I had
weightlifting gloves and you borrowed
them to go out like one night like
Fonzie in that's my capezios they match
it
oh so [__] we went I tried to call
you
nobody answered I go up Cathy and I
finally had the school call me back and
Cathy got on the phone and I said listen
they they found out about Ted well I had
no idea how they found anything out I
told her to come get me but in the
meantime the cops went to my house
knocked on the door open the didn't kick
open the door they got the landlord to
open the door you were at work they they
didn't go inside they you know then
they're real cops then in the search the
place or anything they came out they
they acknowledged I wasn't there and
what they did was they put a police car
on the edge of the block so Cathy King
was coming to get me I got no reason
how's this gonna work out so I walked
around on the block the long way and I
snuck in my backyard I gave Hercules a
kiss I got my weed and I walked back and
for the cops sitting there and me
walking in front of the cops and them
not knowing it was me like this is just
craziness then Cathy king came and got
me out of Wednesday I called you from a
payphone you had already known the cops
were looking for me
and Thursday morning my name came out in
the paper remember the story came out
the bold the camera the bold the camera
and that's what [__] you up that Jim
Roberto called you over and said look
your buddy's name is in the paper and
that crushed you that crushed me
I made the bold of paper for kidnapping
at first it said Stephen did wall and
they're looking for an accomplice and
Wednesday and they thought it was
connected to that dude in a parking lot
that's all this is what people on this
day
I'm trying to say it all so I didn't
turn myself in because this has been a
string of this [__] had been going on I
didn't know what they knew what they
didn't know you didn't know nobody knew
and you didn't even know gee well that
good the cops didn't even come see you
know I stayed up I went I got Kathy King
to drive me up to the house on Thursday
night I said let me go back into town
and I got a copy of above the law and
lethal weapon there were the hottest
movies of the week out
I rented them I went up there and that
Friday I said you know what Don
Johnson's gonna marry now listen no the
one that Prince Phuc from Australia
Oh Sheena Easton uh Don Johnson was
gonna marry a Miami Vice yeah yeah let
me turn myself in this is time to let
the people at home listen this is too
how [__] up my world was I just
finished kidnapping now it had all been
released in the paper guy got caught in
a guy in a trunk of a car with a machine
gun and I'm gonna complement accomplice
I go down to get the movies on dirtier
than iris there's a Kmart across the
street from Coco's and there's an
Albertsons I go to the cow business
first
I buy some groceries and then I go get
my movies and then I go you know what
let me call these [__] cops and see
what's going on I [__] call the cop
they left a number of bill crowd sugru I
called the cop and he goes hold on they
can't put me on old old old old tracing
the call I was trying to trace the call
I kept holding call a hanging up on them
and I told them I I know exactly what
you [__] are doing
you try to trace the call and they go
Jose turn yourself in where are you and
I go you know where I am
come meet me I'm at the Albertson's on
30th Street I wasn't no [__]
Albertsons I was in the parking lot of a
Bose pizza so I could see them straight
on so as I'm rolling my joint I could
see the SWAT trucks and cop cars pull up
with their gang guns drawn and they all
flew into Albertsons and I'm like I'm in
trouble that's what I realized I did
something wrong something's not right
here
and my cocaine head I just stole a
couple of ounces from a guy I did the
job the cops a favor yeah and then that
Friday I woke up that my cocaine mine
again I told my wife to drop me off to
get a hold of you and that would be out
mighty afternoon I'm a girl named Tom
for the cops I'll be out by Miami Vice
make sure you get Chinese food and tell
George I love them I'll see him later
and then I walked in to ring their Bell
and I'm going who are you and I'm like
Oh Sadie is high and then go hold on
they'll be a sergeant opening the door
for you and I'll never forget him
opening the door and ten cops we had
that guns pawn and then I got on your
hands and knees you're getting charged
with kidnapping one kidnapping two
aggravated robbery and I'm like I'd
still remember you coming to visit me
yeah you came to the to the town Boulder
County Jail took me two weeks to get out
and then when I got out that was when it
was sat between you and I there was
nothing you could say there was nothing
I could say I let you down I thought you
thought in your mind you have let me
down but you didn't I have let you down
I had put you in this bad position now
Jim Roberto I was surprised that did
well
didn't even mention me Kidwell squeal
like him like him yeah yeah he ratted me
out completely you know this against the
law what happened but you know there was
no honor among thieves he was but I was
really surprised I mean you I was you
didn't mention me at all and I didn't do
anything
well no I'd be I didn't think about it
I strongly considered without Kidwell
just walking take it and that no not
even having contact with anybody
does it look like an easy score it
wasn't obvious what it was too easy to
be true and that's why I got came they
became more than it should when again
you desperate times desperate measures
you weren't in the right mind you know
and and you put trust in somebody that
it's not the kind of guy you rammed oh
no I was looking for a go look like a
wimp would have gone yeah ey Rambo too
many time nah he was a set not even a
tough guy he was only ones more fatigues
he had he had a pitbull he had his
sunglasses he had a tattoo his car had
tinted windows the Haven said war was a
man who you know George's from Cliffside
I'm from North Bergen and they said we
have like a code where I come from you
know you're never gonna see us with a
scarf or a hoodie or a goatee that's
perfect
Kidwell had all those things
Ted Wall had everything that a man
needed to get attention
and nobody gave a [__] about I mean
there's a [__] but anyway that that's
not add anything so about two months
passed
we don't say much you know we live in
the same house I'm heartbroken I know
you're heartbroken you know and you got
a job in the city your mom got you a job
working for Gloria Vanderbilt or
whatever and and you go back
New York and I could tell you sad you
know now you know what you promised me
this job with Leona Helmsley never helps
we we own the helm was with a hotel
which I didn't get like I didn't even
get a job but it was time for me to go
no it was time for you to go again you
were going to let you know you know you
were working now you were working again
he was selling cause all I was doing I
was doing everything to stay out of
prison and it seemed that the now it's
seen you moved in with Manny when I left
right when you I've moved in with Manny
and then we flew you back in August 15 a
trial I saw for you to totally get bad
character witness
yeah he was not very very cool so an ask
me anything about what happened but we
had a going on as I still run Island
that was one of the saddest days in my
life
you flew in on a Sunday and we had to go
to the attorney's office and do like a a
meet with him like he was gonna yeah ask
you different questions and just run you
through it what did you feel the next
day in court
I was scared [__] because the more I
think we party from the second I got I
left yeah oh yeah I think I slept more
hours before I did testify and uh you
know it's a blur it was just you know me
trying to stick up here but didn't
[__] matter
I mean basically I was there to try to
reduce your sentence and people's you
were done you know we all knew it we
just did we just didn't know the number
you know what I mean you didn't know
like it's just like TV you're gonna get
probation because with such an innocent
I can't say innocent but I mean you're
on something from you know a deepest
feeling from the equipment these are get
it will you know but in the Lord's eyes
you know you know it's not that
so it's you know then it's like me
trying to put a bandaid on a gunshot I'm
nah you know what it really was was a
trip to say goodbye before you went away
because there was nothing I was gonna
say I had no revelation I know nothing
to add other than you know I love him
he's my big brother he takes care of me
you know they didn't give a [__] what I
was a [__] you know I'm walking back
there with my suit on and waving at you
goodbye and I felt very disappointed
like you were there Duffy was there
Russo was there there it was all right
thing I mean it was hard when I left I
just told my dad you know to send me a
ticket home that was a hard you know he
picked me up at the airport you know
there was no internet there was no you
know he didn't know it was going on so
you know my dad grew to really love you
it's weird because he he was a good cop
he was a street cop when he heard all of
his [__] I mean obviously was
disappointed and he doesn't really you
know he's still alive in Florida he's a
good man and uh you know it was just
hard to tell him if he was still on the
job you know what I mean so but he loves
you he loves you movies he loves you
know I mean I learn but he was really
disappointed and you were like a thing I
couldn't really disappoint everybody was
disappointed I mean I was disappointed I
was disappointed in myself but it was
nothing I could do once I got on there I
said to myself there was nothing I could
do but that week before I got arrested
the reason why I named my name that name
Grant few Smith was because I didn't
like Grant few Smith at all I didn't
like what he stood for he was like a
redneck he was a Vegas guy he was very
neat but Grant fused mister was the
first person
that came up to me and he goes do you
mind me having a word with you you know
like when you don't really like somebody
you again ma'am was what he was I just
want to tell you that just what I did
before I did this for a living and I go
what he goes I was a Vegas guy I worked
in Vegas and he goes if I know one thing
you're a true comedian he goes you
should get into comedy uh you should try
it
you should try stand-up and I told him
to get the [__] away from me and now I
feel like hunting him down and I lay
your balls on his face so what'd you do
that with cop sucks when you left
yeah I didn't see you from 87 88 to 91
I told away I well then I saw you for
the wedding
you came to my wedding at 89 it was that
which was Miriam just pictures on the
flint on the plane to go to your wedding
and working at the gallery and I have
two or three pictures back when they
were stewardesses not flight attendants
and you know they're walking in with
these two big things flirt with the the
hot chick you know put these with your
coke goes there no problem that off the
plane with these two things and then I I
didn't remember the wedding I didn't
remember you coming to the wedding
cuz Ronnie was right
we got the raid his plane got the way he
was too [__] up and he was well but he
didn't get there in time so I was an
usher and then last minute I was your
best man and I'm like and that was I
mean that that man that wedding I can't
believe that when it even went off I
that was the crew that was there Tommy
Russo and wealth I was little Ronnie
does a lot of crazy from not very I
I start with Ronnie and he had been up
from the night before
Marylou yeah yeah we even married Lou I
mean it was just a lot of people there
my probation officer was there cuz I got
I got married nine nine of 89
September 9th of 89 so I already had an
eight ball in my pocket I got especially
sad that dude from Florida the guy did I
didn't know was really good guy
Spanish time it was Cuban talk that was
the first time I met a B AB and guy he
had what he had a big bag yeah there was
a guy who know there was a gun when Leo
Rodriguez and then I didn't see you know
from out there it was a guy from out
there that's I'm Sam he was a Cuban
Eddie Julio Rodriguez he was a Cuban guy
his father was the best Pookie the best
pool player in Cuba who came to Cuba to
play against him Sinatra Gleason Wow so
he was known as the best B Island Kula
the kids doing something now he's a
big-time poker player but that's what
you meant Julio Rodriguez he was a
different kid but oh so now you leave me
for the wedding 91 I show back up at
your house it's a different time now
yeah we're not doing coke no more I'm
still doing coke you're smoking crack or
whatever the [__] you're doing up there
in the Bronx
I went back there for a week and all we
did together was party and then I came
back by that time I had already gotten
on stage this is when you first started
right oddest I knew something wasn't
right and then I went to visit you my
wife told me she knows something's going
on
with you you might need a little
vacation go to New York I went to New
York they gave me a white [__] car
like a white Cadillac I ran and it was
white cop car so I would take George
into the city the cop and nobody want to
talk to us because they thought we had a
[__] cop car so we couldn't get coca
Wiis from anywhere was a [__]
nightmare so I come back I stay with
George for ten days eight days too many
cuz it was just too much it was like I
went back [__] blown out of my head
and you know I think I was back a month
before she said we're gonna get a
divorce and then I went yeah that's what
did it I think he wrapped up the credit
card Scootaloo she was she was flipping
and then I [__] got into comedy
full-time really was working it in the
beginning long slices off getting the
whole thing and then I handed me a note
book you handed me a note book and
you're saying just just do me a favor
whatever you do whatever just keep write
just write whatever and then we'll talk
about then what's a while I would
scribble soft but every time I'm taking
you to all these different you needed to
bring somebody to get on stage right so
93 I get into trouble I call you you're
in trouble you had to go away for a
while I wait for you to get out of your
situation and now you and me are a team
made in hell you got your own plan a
country club and I got my own [__]
problem with staying with Grandma but
you and I both know it that we call each
other once a month and talk about one of
those nights at Grandma's house cuz
every night was an adventure at
Grandma's house it was me and I and I
could tell you people right now
if you were if we would have put those
that footage on tape Seinfeld wouldn't
have had a career right now
nothing is funnier then that show what
is no that's grandma right there and
Lee's got some footage of grandma saying
some racist stuff we're gonna dig well
yeah we had that documentary she she
she's the missing part of that
documentary she was she was him my
family had a respect they they pulled it
but she passed and I'm dying to see it
because I gotta tell you one thing she
was [__] she was on the roll that day
hell she was on the roll that day so I
moved in with you in 93 and I'm cutting
my teeth in comedy yeah I'm cutting my
teeth in calmly I mean I had stand-up
comedy by Judy Carter I live down the
bed you lived on the couch we weren't
even social distancing room they would
have got on these two guys again cuz the
beds get close to one another and I
think I stayed with you for nine months
from February to October of 80 of 94 93
and if I have to like you know like what
President Trump came on and there was a
couple of weeks ago he goes yeah America
isn't going to the toughest tree we see
your life if it wasn't for the humor
that was going on between our lives I
wouldn't have been here right now that
was the toughest time that was the
toughest I ever worked in my life as a
human being frustrated confused but I
knew what I wanted do you know I'm
saying
you were selling cause in the city you
were getting pamphlets those though you
were going to offices giving those you
know like like book in like your office
to come to a common a comic strip or
whatever you were doing that thing and
you were going onstage any open mind
any opening with anyone it was a the
work I was leaving the house
seven-thirty is that all is that because
mr. Rago used to drive the bus and yeah
if I didn't take the 7 o'clock bus I
would have to pay a dollar yeah I didn't
even have the dial to get on the bus mr.
Rago will let me on the bus at 7:30 in
the morning I would go into this and I'm
not sure crisp I have the egg-white
shirt
one white shirt but I wore the same
shirt every day this is why when people
come to me and tell me they're working
and this is what I'm doing I laugh
because I know the results from hard
work our house at 7 I was working till I
was at the car lapto eight of nine in
between eight and nine I would run over
to a boxing gym I paid $25 a month for a
lot t-shirts and the shirt there so when
I left 57th and 12th was where I worked
I worked on 57th and twelve at 11th
Avenue down there and a Nissan Demasi
Cadillac and when I yeah there I would
run to the gym do a little [__] [__]
workout hit the bag lift some weights I
would put on stand-up comedy clothes and
I would bum around the clubs in the city
and then when I got sick of selling cars
I went to work at hash ways at lunchtime
yeah I would get up in North Bret listen
to what I would do I would wake up and
clear-sighted grandmas and walk to where
s he lives to the to where that hotel
where they built that hotel and Tunnel
II Avenue yeah they had a gym there on
the third floor I had grown up with
those kids when I was a kid their house
there their father's business burned
down and my mother helped him so they
told me you don't have to pay for the
membership just come so I was at jumping
it was no I wasn't jumping these are two
Cuban kids ah this is on 67th Street and
Tunnel II Avenue there's all there's a
hotel there now commitment of my work
at that age at that age it was 1993 I
was 30 I would get up at 8:00 and walk
from Cliffside Park in Jersey to 67th
Street down the hill do a weightlifting
workout take a shower walk up the hill
to North Bergen the hash ways I work and
I'd worked till 2:00 I deliver the
sandwiches and then I'd run to your
house take a shower and put a suit on
and I would go drive a limo geez I don't
know yeah I drove a limo and I would go
to you I would go to Fort leaf I would
go to Englewood Cliffs and pick up the
newsreels the NBC news I was working for
a guy named Alan Stiglitz I would go
pick up the reels for MBC news and I
would bring him across the bridge and
that would give me 35 bucks already
so I would start I was hustling like 150
to 200 cash and hash ways and then I
would run home make money selling coke
going into the city for people and then
I would get in a delivery car and then
my rides would usually be at 1 2:30 in
the morning 10 so I would just do open
mics in between those yeah and then at
10:00 I would go to get old triple in
and sign in for open mikes and go back
there and do deliveries and before 4
a.m. I would get up at night that was
the end of my night and I still remember
being on that bed with you many a night
like the nights I did take off it was
because you were taken off and we would
try to write jokes and I still remember
the first joke we wrote together it was
about speakers one of those good
speakers that you are those home
speakers something happened that the the
[__] we wrote to Jos together this is
our first it was the boy Rican Day
Parade
don't parade do might think up both I
think a boat crashed in the huts in the
Sun yes that was my first joke about me
right the point alberto Rica sees that
we'll where we live is the Hudson River
odds so the one size in New York the
other side's Jersey but the Puerto
Ricans and Cubans it based a picnic on
the Jersey side of the Hudson in his
Beach that was like a foot and a half
warm and they would go in the water lie
[__] cream I guess you know cuz it's
on the Jersey they thought it was like
[__] the vets the way it was a giant
pipe with this black sludge coming out
of it
oh great and they would [__] float
around like like we're not in the Bronx
anymore yeah it's not the Jersey Shore
it's a [__] two feet or 18 inches of
[__] black dirt sand always hilarious
but the first time the first two jokes
rewrote were about Porto Rican Day
Parade the Puerto Rican Navy crashed
into the ship 400 Puerto Ricans in the
Hudson that's not the new that was the
first show and the second joke was about
what the Hells Angels were back one of
those guys that John Gotti shot in the
leg remember they used to patrol the
streets of New York with law the
guardian angels were back and somebody
put in the front page the guardian
angels are back and we wrote a joke the
guardian angels are back time to put the
bow speakers back in the windows or
something like that those are our first
two successful writing jokes and I think
that me staying with you those eight
months like you and I could go I was
about how we used to torture grandma uh
one night you put the fan in the window
I was really hurt I was doing coke and
you came at it too you know like why you
sweating on my choice shut up
I don't want grandma to know and you're
like no I don't worry I brought you a
sandwich I brought your daily news
and you want to put the fan in the
window and the fan fell out of the
window
good morning oh my god and grandma what
the [__] is going on and were like
grandma you know the deal here it's it's
[__] play the win here every night
you know
grandma would had a big dong and the
kids in the living room it was a big guy
ancient table top but it was like a
giant guy it was a giant [__] guy we
hang it on the wall yeah and [__] I
would wait for grandma to go to sleep
and get comfy and I would see George tip
topping to the room to go do a bump and
as soon as the door would lock I would
get up and hit the bong with everything
I got I'm gonna lay back in bed and
grandma I would come out and go what the
[__] just happened she go with George I
don't know he's in the bathroom
that [__] he's doing [__] again
and he'd run to the bathroom and that
was the end of it
George hey my you know the part of his
charm koko is my grand my grandmother
was from Panama so growing up I didn't
have any you know I broke a clear sign
not the verse was Italian
that was it my el cheapo but as I became
a young a younger adult like my two best
friends were acutely Coco and then I had
Sammy Medina Berto Rican whose father
was the John Gotti of the Puerto Rican
mom living in Englewood Cliffs Sammy
Medina god bless and now he's born again
but he was crazy back then and those
whom I too might mind my two buddies
like you know I didn't have there was
nobody close like that was Spanish and I
never admitted I was fancies they'd hear
my grandmother talk and I just hated
Italian time but it's better she loved
him because he could cost vanish I would
always folks pass to your grandma she
the grandma became my grandma what was
so important to her to be able to speak
Spanish this to get she'sshe's in Hawaii
she look at it cliffside too
there's no there's no one to talk to
other than Who
on the phone but she loved you more you
know she was always so proud man I put a
movie on and she'd be like that's not
called go I'm going that's [__] Coco
and when I got the big screen TV Oh
when she saw you she grinned even here
just like my mom my mom did you know my
mom used to go early days to go see it I
remember holcomb up for your mom and
Alice and her girl in Plano Texas she
would come to see me at the Dallas yeah
yeah George we got we went over our time
limits but uh ah it's been a tremendous
41 years being your friend anybody ever
wants to know anything about me the
truth
this guy will tell you this is why I
brought him on because he knows my
strengths my weaknesses what I love what
I hate he knows I love him we talk when
we talk three times a day at least
people you know listen I gotta say I
enjoyed Steve Novello and Dennis you
know there's stuff that I didn't know
something I didn't know you were young
so you know fills in the blanks and well
what I want to know is he's real you
know I see this [__] army and we went
to you went to [__] uh got the
theater that the first night had truly
hit me that you were you aren't to
something bigger than just you know you
had a [__] army of people outside
that Gotham theater we're gonna add at a
car but block and a half from the
frickin club and people are walking up
here and as we got there there was just
like 250 strong just chanting your name
and I was like holy [__] I mean I was
stoned as a I was like a two-dose guy he
would ghost me way before you George was
a foreman George George it was oh my god
I would go to these shows trying to stop
t-shirts I didn't even know my name yeah
he would bring merch I'd be like
dribbling on myself and you also got to
know you
you became time with Ralphie you became
growling around we all go back with
Ralphie to North burg and the hatchways
to get all rice pudding
you know from Ralphie you go back we
gave Kyle my house Coco was early comedy
Ralphie would come pick him up driving
to the airport I didn't watch Last Comic
Standing I had no [__] idea no idea
no I just would pop out I don't even
know it was fat he was said he was fans
in a big escalate or something you know
I say I hire you don't and then when we
became friends it was uh you know as
close as he wants to Coco he treated me
whenever you every every bit of because
he knew my story you know you knew my
story and that's one guy you know truly
miss truly truly tell these people that
sometimes you don't really have to come
out of your mom's womb to have a brother
absolute benefit gift you know you you
were my my picture still my big [__] me
well a little months apart but you know
uh you know we take a like you know you
give me advice I don't listen to it you
get [__] mad a couple times you went
a few months where you know you put me
on knockoff because you love me because
you you know you see I do song you know
I think with my heart not my brain
sometimes so let me tell you brother not
me first only from one thought my
ex-wife loves you my thought is you know
you're just good to everybody you know
what I mean you guys all do you [__]
know I [__] - but you know what
you're all I got
it's it's been a 40-year people will
usually don't have [__] nothing for
four years I've had a brother for 40
years and to make it official let's just
say 35 [__] years so I love that you
took the time to come on and just share
a few stories
to let these [__] know we
weren't [__] around this is real was
a different time and Dennis said loyalty
how I'll give my right arm for you I
don't give a [__] know what you
always have we I I give what I got and
that's what we do we don't always have
what we got we share because love each
other and you know no one's prouder of
you nobody man he nobody's proud no I'm
proud of you than me brother in
quarantine here and I can count on my
hands how many people checkup you know
and you'd be surprised when you know I'm
divorced my kid is not that far I see
you but I go to bed alone every night
and the people that I talk to it's
really important because you know it's
the people I care about so me you're
number one in my book always you're
number one in my book I like that in
filming my grandmother Lee all right
we'll get it out there
I think you're doing two parts thank you
for doing the whole week a lot of no I
love your brother have a good one
Yuto dirty [__]
I want to thank George again for laying
it down listen like I told you I got a
thousand stories I could tell you but
10,000 I can't tell you we covered what
we could today I just want to open my
world up to you guys to see how lucky
I've been as a human being that listen
guys these guys weren't my friends when
I was at The Comedy Store these guys
weren't my friends when I was on the set
of The Longest Yard these guys weren't
my friends when you know I was in the
southern Sopranos these guys with my
friends when people call me a spec when
people call me a thief and what people
were not saying nice things about me and
I didn't deserve from say nice things
about me but at the same time these guys
are my friends
when there was nothing man and they're
the friends that matter in your [__]
life believe it or not you know I'm
saying
I learned this I see this every day I
know who's my friend because of movies
and now and I know the people I'll take
a bullet off they'll take a bullet for
me
and that's a very great thing to have in
your life knowing I see the differences
these are my childhood friends you know
so I'm fortunate enough that they'll do
me the favor and do these things that
are movie stars they're not [__] rock
stars then I [__] models they're just
blue collar people exactly what I am
exactly what you are
what's up Lee this is a new cuz I think
a lot of people during this time are
reaching out to people and it is nice
but you you've been doing this for years
but how how does it make you feel when
you talk to one of these P how do you
feel after a conversation like 40
minutes with one of your friends from
back then on the phone and everything
yeah as soon as I get off the phone I
always ask myself I can't believe I
still talk to them and I think of her
and I do it every day there's always
somebody Conte Duffy I'm still supposed
to coy you know my other friend James
Devo a lot of people have asked me to
put Devo on I gotta call him and ask him
if he'll come on but how does it make me
feel like a rich man like a lot of
people think having money makes you feel
good and all this [__] I know a ton of
people that have funds of money and they
don't have the relationships I have with
my friends to where I do and they were
then then you gotta remember like George
has been there you know George ran away
at to open mikes like he went to - oh he
said it he left me at - open mics he
left me at 127th Street you know that's
how long I've known George you know
Stephenville oh I didn't see in the
beginning of comedy but he knew what I
was doing and Dennis knew what I was
doing you know and when I put joyful ATO
on his cousin was there a lot of people
remember
you know Mike a Scalise Devo who were
talking about a lot of people he turned
me on to David Letterman and I would go
to his house every night once David let
him to watch all the comedians on David
Letterman so these are the people that
have been there with me since day one I
feel great I feel great that I still
have the ability to talk to them they
also know all the bad things I did and
they talked to me because they know the
reasons why I did it and it's forgiven
it's a known it's forgiven it's done it
doesn't matter it's not where you start
the journey it's where you end it you
know what a bloody is have a lot of
friends that were way ahead of you
went to college got married got houses
you felt insecure and also they
discovered crack you had already done
crack when you were 13 you moved on with
your life and awesome here they are
living at a bus station and here you are
you own the house now because it's not
really where you start it's where you
fought and that's the lesson for this
four [__] week don't forget
tonight UFC [__] my bookie
dot AG what's the code jelly right Joey
I'm just listen it's not about [__] the
money I'm just helping you [__]
out so you can make some cash tonight
my bookie that AG Joey made a little
money you got some to watch tonight how
good is that you got some to watch on
the Wednesday night Jesus Christ
you ever try watching TV at night listen
I get so [__] depressed at night
I don't even going to the TV room like
this times I go into the TV room and the
TV is off and my right my wife is
reading a [__] book that's how like
we gave up on the TV I didn't watch
ozarks I didn't watch exotic joke I
don't want to watch none of that [__] I
don't I don't really want to get
involved I wanted to see who the [__] I
was for the first time in a long time I
got to have a long talk of myself when
was the last time you have a long talk
with yourself have one this weekend see
we end up I'm saying you need to have a
long talk
yourself the unemployment check hasn't
come the landlord keeps throwing daggers
at you you say he's about to light the
building on fire cuz you and your two
other buddies haven't paid the rent but
you don't give a [__] there's no debtors
prison take care of your health take
care of your mind take care of your body
and I promise you this will pass I don't
give a [__] how many times they extend
it I don't give a [__]
we're gonna make it through this all
right I love you [__] with all
my butt real quick I got a couple of
things I got to talk to you about number
one you got to shave your nuts
all right I'm sick and [__] just cuz
it's depression Ville and just because
you're not gonna see a chick don't mean
you're gonna leave your bush down there
to grow on Tam and you dick the smell
like [__] jolie exotic whatever it's
[__] name is right now right now is
the time to wash your balls you know
it's number one cure depression washing
your balls if you were done I'm so
depressed I can't masturbate
take that [__] bongo dick out and
tell mama to show you a titties and bang
one out that's what gets you [__] on
the press you [__] piece of [__]
people get the press kept the press
because it's yes it's a disease and it's
or whatever but you let yourself slide
into that you see yourself sliding into
that get in the shower get in the car go
for walk talk to people
number one shave your balls I find that
to be the number one cure for depression
shaving your [__] nutsack and I'm no
psychiatrist right thank you but think
about it even if you're a woman you're
depressed you're like I haven't gotten
[__] in a year we'll start by looking at
your [__] you know what I forgot I got
a nice-looking little [__] will you two
guys you got a nice-looking a little
dick but you gotta shave around it needs
some [__] trimming and right now
manscape is the time to do it if you're
gonna trim your balls buddy got you got
no baseball you got no basketball you
got the UFC tie plants a perfect night
to shave your nuts in between rounds
just take your dick out with the menses
right there and you pick up on that then
you split some Reviver on those [__]
things
remember when you were kid the [__]
barber would put like alcohol after he
[__] [__] don't do that no more
because they're a bunch of [__]
jerk-offs but after you shave your nuts
you like to revive and you [__] take
your nutsack and you squeeze them and
fill them there and squeeze them but a
little Bob the little boy used to have
at the end of your bicycle like that put
some of that on there and the [__]
crop preserver and that's what you get
with the perfect package listen I'm
gonna tell you again
[__] that a lot more 3.0 is the best
razor system you're gonna ever own in
your life and it's waterproof so you
could use it in the shower after you
bang one out there you go dip dip your
dick is really good I mean this thing is
juiced with 7,000 rpm motor and a
battery that lasts up to 90 minutes USB
charging an LED light so you can see
into all those nooks and crannies I told
you [__] I'm not lying to you
and if you get the perfect package today
they're gonna send you the lawnmower
plus the crop preserver so your balls
won't stick together plus the Reviver so
they'll smell like [__] flowers the
way my nut wants my my nuts leave my
sure but this one no don't say sure
because in this podcast of all to a
different category and now you can
subscribe get a new blade every three
months that's how you keep your balls
extra clean new nice blades and they'll
throw in two of my favorite thing a pair
of a free shipping boxes and ready for
this the travel bag which has a little
zipper inside in the back it's dark you
didn't hear from me listen do yourself a
favor this is for the church family go
to manscape calm preston code Joey
Jo ey and get 20% off and free shipping
that's all I'm taking care you thought I
had on Wednesday 20% off and free
shipping they don't give a [__] of your
mother okay that's Joey and manscaped
calm for 20% off and free shipping now
you got a nice-looking big what are you
gonna do with it whatever your fancy
suit for Charlie
job the word same thing applies listen
remember when you dick used to get hard
remember when you would just be [__]
watching like SportsCenter can you be
watching let's leave this so whatever
the name was a little red-haired do you
know she doesn't throw a good [__]
you looking at it going [__] I would
like that lassie this suck my dick right
now it's 1108 she's talking about
basketball [__] it
but now you can't do that you know why
cuz you don't have confidence in
yourself because you got a weak would I
got the same problem what am I gonna
waste this game I got I got game game
[__] my can't be wasting it because I
can't give me the dick I can't cover
this product I used to but I'm 24 but
now I can thank God - blue Chu [__]
tremendous it's the first chewable dicto
which means that works fast alright what
do you mean Joey fast fast
bucho has the same fda-approved active
ingredients as Viagra and Cialis and
this isn't the horny goat weed you get
them down the [__] convenience store
blue Chu is a prescribed online by
licensed physicians so you don't have to
go to the doctor's office or wait in
line at the pharmacy and it ships right
to your door and the discreet package
nobody knows nothing and since blue Chu
ships direct that cheaper than the
pharmacy listen to me come on and the
best thing of everything there's no
awkwardness why because you have to go
to a doctor you'd have to explain
yourself
but Joey what's so good about a chewable
dick oh then you could take it any time
day and night even on a full stomach
and since they're chewable they work up
twice as fast as a pill turn your
[__] piece of [__] dick into a
Maserati you've been looking at it for
[__] too long being a shame like I
did I was ashamed for a long time after
my little [__] accident my dick wasn't
getting hard you think that's gonna stop
the savage [__] no I mean how he [__]
like a [__] like a throwdown but I
need to shoot a [__] school tour from
time to time and
my blood pressure goes up I'm telling
you you should do the same right now
right now turn that [__] dick into a
savage go to the church family go to
blue shoe calm that's blue blue2 CH e
you.com eww he'd uh be I'm sorry when I
say you whatever eat W and get your
first shipment free you just pay five
hours for shipping is that good ever
what you fill out some papers you go to
the blue shoe calm you answer some
questions fill out some papers you feel
like you answer some questions your
[__] talk to the doctor a couple days
later boom there they are in the mail
your sling and dick like [__] Mike
double X whatever his name is I don't
know they be good-looking do it it
doesn't really matter it's time for you
to get back on your game this thing some
dick you got to give somebody a good
quarantine stabbing you know I'm saying
call them back two days later though
we're going out for drinks [__] no I'm
still recovering from that quarantine
dick he gave me two days ago it's like I
got passed around in the prison if you
want your dick to be that hard
blue to calm alright get your first
shipment free when you press code Church
and that's it pay files to chipping hit
that blue to dog thank you thank you for
listening thank you for George thank you
for manscaped I want to thank my bookie
don't forget tonight my bookies gonna
make you some money you got to share to
[__] up Teixeira against [__] Anthony
yeah I forget I don't know the whole
[__] lineup I'm Tanya I'm confused
with three times four I'm doing this
homeschooling it's draw Emile dates I
don't got nothing
you're getting your money back from Live
Nation for [__] Dallas and whatever
take it all back guys right now we're
gonna start from scratch hopefully when
the Improv opens up and Brad I'll be
doing my bi-weekly
Tuesday night show getting my chops back
and you guys will be a part of it until
then stay in stay safe don't let nobody
breathe on you don't let nobody [__]
with you and I love you have a great
weekend
see you Monday morning tip-top
[__] Magoo
[Music]